today we'll be explaining the top 10
strongest pirate crews in one piece
we'll start with the cross Guild and in
later parts of the video we'll cover
some of the Legendary Pirate Crews that
are feared by everyone around the world
cross Guild is the newest pirate crew
introduced to the story consisting of
three former Warlords of the sea buggy
mihawk and crocodile out of any crew the
cross Guild definitely has the most
interesting creation Story by far the
company was initially created by a
partnership between crocodile and mihawk
in order to hunt down Marines for
bounties now to fund this organization
crocodile realized he needed money so we
went to Buggy to call up on a huge debt
that the latter owed him when he got
there he inadvertently saved buggy from
the Marine Fleet that was attacking him
because of this buggies employees
thought that crocodile actually saved
him out of loyalty and created a poster
that made it seem that buggy was in
charge of the entire cross Guild when
the world government saw that mihawk and
crocodile were supposedly serving under
buggy they immediately promoted him to
Emperor level and gave him the Bounty of
3 billion 180 nine million bellies the
most interesting thing about this
organization is that it's putting
bounties on the Marines which no one has
tried to do before however it seems that
the Bounty amounts are indicated by
symbols instead of money this is really
unfortunate since it would be very
interesting to see what would some of
the Admiral bounties look like at the
end of each crew will also estimate what
each crew's total Bounty would probably
be and some of the numbers will be
totally insane we currently know the
bounties of all cross Guild members so
their combined Bounty should be around 9
billion bellies number nine big mom
Pirates the big bomb Pirates are a large
and Powerful pirate group whose
territory is known as total land a fairy
tale World containing seemingly
Whimsical creatures who have a dark side
to them the group's leader is big bomb
and 85 out of 129 members are actually
her children man she should get her own
reality TV show 85 children and Counting
even at a young age big mom had these
hunger pains which are moments when she
can't control herself and start feeding
every stay in her path this is exactly
how she obtained her devil fruit
after unknowingly eating its previous
owner besides big mom the crew's three
strongest Pirates are called sweet
commanders and they're Charlotte
katakuri Charlotte cracker and Charlotte
smoothie an interesting fact about this
crew is that it has the highest amount
of no members by far I mean just look at
the official wiki there has to be around
100 known members in here the big mom
Pirates are feared around the world with
many races being terrified of them a
good example of this is that Fishman
Island citizens feared big moms so much
that they agreed to produce 10 tons of
candy she orders every month another
reason everyone fears her is because she
hunts the people that don't hit the
Subscribe button just make sure to hit
it and you should be fine the majority
of other Pirates are also scared of her
and it's common knowledge that if big
mom invites you to her tea party you
better come since if you refuse you'll
probably be sent a box with the head of
someone close to you now some of you may
be wondering if they're really stronger
than the cross Guild so let's explain
that you see although the insane
insanely powerful mihawk and Sir
crocodile are members of the Cross Guild
there aren't any other notable members
besides them so unless you consider
buggy alvita or Mr three to be strong
Pirates I really don't see away mihawk
and crocodile could take on the entire
big bomb screw by themselves it's
impossible all many members of the big
bomb Pirates have their boundings
revealed so if we add the estimated
batteries of all the other less
important members the numbers should be
around 11 billion 500 million bellies
with big mom covered we still have eight
incredibly strong cruise to cover and
the next one is everyone's favorite
Straw Hat Pirates the straw hat Pirates
are the primary pirate crew of the
series they were formed in the East Blue
by Monkey D Luffy and since then the
crew has made a name for themselves by
defeating many formidable foes and
sailing through the Grand line and New
World in addition they have successfully
liberated Nations like alabasta Fishman
Island dress Rosa and even wano which
was ruled by the world's strongest
creature and Emperor kaido it's also
important to mention that they may
managed to achieve all of this in only
two years from the start of their
Journey despite their small size of only
10 active members the straw hats are an
extremely diverse group their members
Origins range from ordinary Islanders
and workers to bounty hunters royalty
criminal gang members and Veteran
Pirates at the end of the dressrosa arc
the crew also became the leaders of an
alliance called the straw hat Grand
Fleet which involves seven pirate groups
that sided with Luffy in his conflict
with doflamingo this Alliance consists
of 5 640 people who pledged their
loyalty to Luffy and promised to come to
his Aid whenever he needs them from the
beginning straw hats have always set out
to do what no one had thought possible
and for that many considered them insane
however despite this they managed to
achieve almost impossible things like
finding the sky island invading Annie's
Lobby and defeating cp9 infiltrating
Toto land and participating in an
assassination attempt against big mom
and even attacking the Beast pirate
stronghold in onigashima although Luffy
is by far the strongest member of the
crew many others all also possess
notable strengths some examples are the
pirate Hunter Roberto Zorro blackleg
Sanji and former warlord jinbei which
all have bounties of over 1 billion
bellies based on Luffy's new powers that
he awakened during his battle against
kaido and the crew's overall strength
they should be able to beat the big bomb
pirates in all vs all battle the
individual bounties of all Straw Hat
members are revealed and the combined
Bounty for all of them is exactly 8
billion 816 million 1 000 bellies number
seven Blackbeard Pirates the Blackbeard
Pirates are a dangerous opportunistic
evil ragtag group and currently one of
the four strongest crews in the world
they're led by Marshall D teach a man
who aims to find the one piece just like
many before him and shake the world
forever he's cutting this in dedication
know no bounds as he spent over a decade
as a member of Whitebeard pirates only
because he wanted to use them to find
the devil fruit he was searching for the
yummy yummy no me the interesting thing
about Blackbeard Pirates is that before
the time skip they actually used a
wooden raft instead of a ship I mean
imagine sailing over the ground line
with this these guys are on a completely
different level even before the time
skip Blackbeard Pirates were a force to
be reckoned with as they managed to
attack drum Island break into impel
Down's fourth level and survive
sengoku's punch with little to no damage
however after the time skip they became
even stronger with level 6 prisoners
joining the crew in Blackbeard acquiring
the powers of the go to go to know me As
proved of their strength after the time
skip they easily defeated the Whitebeard
Pirates who wanted to take revenge on
them and seize their former territories
although there's some notable members
like Jesus Burgess shiruyu of the rain
and vanagar as of now we don't know what
bounties they have and how strong they
really are also the Blackbeard Pirates
have recently gained a powerful Ally the
former Marine Admiral kuzan making them
even more dangerous based on all this
I'm not really sure if the straw hats
would be able to defeat them especially
considering Blackbeard's ability to
nullify the powers of others also since
we don't have much Bounty information
about this crew I'll have to take a
guess if we count aokiji as the crew
member I don't think it's a stretch to
say that the crew's total Bounty is
probably around 11 billion bellies
number six Golden Lion Pirates before
the events of Roger's execution in
logtown Shiki and the Golden Lion
Pirates were one of the major players in
the sea Shiki and his pyro groups were
one of the pirate King's greatest Rivals
they would constantly fight each other
with shiki's crew even having an
advantage a few times Shiki also had the
largest ground Fleet in the world with
over 50 divisions I know what many of
you are saying Shiki is not a Canon
character and therefore he shouldn't be
on the list well despite the majority of
shiki's achievements being non-canon he
and the Golden Lion Pirates are
confirmed Canon characters so it's only
right that I put him on the list the
most interesting thing about this crew
is their ship it's called Island ship
and as the name says it's literally a
land mass with high trees and long oars
rowing at its sides the ship flies too
this is made possible by shiki's devil
which allows him to fly and levitate
other things into the air the other
notable members besides Shiki are
scarlet a giant gorilla and indigo the
crew's scientists unfortunately not much
is known about these characters since
all of their appearances were in movies
and are not canon none of the crew
members including Shiki have known
bounties making it pretty much
impossible to rank them against other
Crews however since they were one of
Roger's biggest Rivals it's undeniable
that they were a very strong crew and
because of that I've put them in at
least above Blackbeard also their Bounty
was probably around 8 to 10 billion
bellies alright from here on the total
bounties start to become pretty insane
and you definitely don't want to miss
the bounties on the two strongest Crews
number five red hair Pirates although
red hair Pirates are mostly shrouded in
mystery they're certainly one of the
strongest pirate Crews ever their leader
is red hair Shanks one of the four
Emperors with an astonishing Bounty of
over 4 billion bellies besides Shanks
the most notable pirates in This Crew
our first mate Ben Beckham cook lucky
Rue and snipe yasop a true Testament to
the crew's strength is that the world
government greatly feared what would
happen if they and the Whitebeard
Pirates were to form an alliance also
during the Battle of marine Ford as soon
as the red hair Pirates appeared all
fighting stopped and no one wanted to
fight against them even tiege who had
two devil fruit Powers at the time
didn't want to engage Shanks and simply
said he wasn't ready to fight him yet
the most interesting thing about the red
hair Pirates is that November including
Shanks as devil fruit Powers you see
this is really interesting for a few
reasons firstly since they're a really
strong crew they definitely had a chance
to eat a powerful devil fruit at some
point but chose not to for unknown
reasons this also means that all the
crew members must be exceptional hockey
users as they were able to survive for
so long in the new world however the
majority of their bounties are currently
unknown so we can't estimate how strong
they really are I went back to reread
some chapters and found out that there
is actually one revealed Bounty beside
Shanks it's the County of the crew's
Apprentice named Rockstar who has a
bounty of 94 million bellies I mean if a
rookie has a bounty this high I can only
imagine what the officer's bounties are
they must all be in billions this would
make my estimate for their total Bounty
around 12 billion bellies number four
Beast Pirates the Beast Pirates were an
emperor crew consisting of animal
hybrids who followed every command of
their Captain kaido the world's
strongest creature in King of the beasts
kaido is an Unstoppable force of nature
whose skin is so tough he survived every
execution attempt on his life and was
believed to be truly Invincible like
this incredible toughness wasn't enough
he also had the mythical zoen type devil
fruit no me which allowed him to
transform into a giant dragon at one
point Beast Pirates attempted to attack
Whitebeard pirates in the hope of
killing Whitebeard something no one in
the world would dare to do they also
managed to conquer wano and had in many
of the country's Samurai working for
them as subordinates the true strength
of This Crew lies in their underworld
connections due to kaido's Alliance on
with doflamingo and Caesar Clown they
had access to Smiles to help form an
army of over 500 artificial Zone devil
fruit users the sheer number of crew
members with smile fruit forced both
Luffy and Zorro to retreat after they
attempted to assault kaido's Castle
other notable members besides kaido are
his right hand man king Jack the drought
and queen despite the overwhelming power
of both kaido and all of his crew
members Straw Hat Pirates eventually
defeated them during the wanna work and
kaido's crew lost the emperor's status
the majority of Beast Pirates bounties
were revealed in the show so their total
Bounty should be similar to red hair
Pirates at around 12 billion bellies
number three white-beard Pirates the
Whitebeard Pirates were formerly one of
the strongest pirate crews in the world
their Captain Whitebeard was one of the
four Emperors and one of the few people
to have ever been a match for the pirate
king in a fight they were very different
from any other pirate Crews as
Whitebeard didn't at all care about
Treasures he instead had a great desire
for family which he believed was the
greatest treasure one could have
Whitebeard commands a massive pirate
Fleet controlling many subordinate crews
in the new world and having 16 divisions
of his own with each one having its
respective Captain whitebeard's Crew is
arguably the one the world government
feared the most because of this they
were prepared to use pretty much the
entire Marines including all Admirals
and seven Warlords of the sea to fight
Whitebeard Pirates and even then they
weren't sure if they'd managed to defeat
them sengoku also said that with his
devil fruit Whitebeard had the power to
destroy the entire world although
newgate's crew was incredibly powerful
they weren't by any means Invincible we
can easily see this during the Marine
Fort Arc where several commanders were
severely injured while trying to save
Ace and when Blackbeard Pirates ambushed
and killed the crew's Captain Whitebeard
some notable members besides Whitebeard
were Marco the Phoenix Ace josu thatch
Vista and at one point even kizuki Odin
himself okay so if we assume that all
the Whitebeard Pirates are currently
alive and that Odin is also part of the
crew the estimated total Bounty should
be around around 13 billion bellies
which is the highest bounty we had so
far on the list before we explain the
absolute strongest crew on the list
let's first cover the Roger Pirates
Roger Pirates were the legendary crew
with Goldie Rogers the captain the screw
traveled around the grand line in search
of laughtail and the things they did
were by many considered to be Legends
like the red hair Pirates Roger's crew
wasn't relying on devil fruit abilities
and Roger himself didn't possess any by
far their most important feat is that
they managed to find all four Road
poneoglyphs and reach the final island
laughtail with this members of the crew
discover the true history of the world
the events of the Void century and the
meaning of the initial D things only a
handful of people in the world know this
led to Roger being given a bounty of 5
billion 564 million eight hundred
thousand bellies the highest recorded
bounty in history sometime after finding
the one piece Roger turned himself in
and his pirate crew was disbanded the
world government executed Roger shortly
after but not before he said his
legendary final words you want my
treasure you can have it I left
everything I gathered together in one
place now you'll just have to find it
even after 25 years since the crew
separation some members still have
active bounties and are constantly
chased by the world government since
Whitebeard and Roger Pirates battled
each other many times over the years and
each time it ended in a draw it's
obvious that the cruiser of almost equal
strength I chose to put Roger Pirates
higher on the list because of their
legacy but it could have easily been the
other way around by now you're probably
wondering what was the Roger Pirates
total Bounty well unfortunately this
information was never revealed by Oda
but I'll still try to answer it if we
assume Odin to be a part of the Rogers
crew I believe their total Bounty was
definitely over 15 billion bellies
number one rocks Pirates imagine being
so powerful and influential that the
world government had to erase you from
all history books and cover up that you
ever existed well this is exactly how
powerful Rock Steve's epic and his
pirate crew were okay you may be
wondering how can this pirate crew be
stronger than some of the other other
Crews we mentioned well you quickly
understand that as soon as I tell you
who were the members of this famous crew
besides Rox who was the captain some of
the others were kaido Charlotte and then
Lin cheeky and even Whitebeard yep you
heard it right the World's Strongest Man
King of the Beast one of the world's
strongest Swordsmen and big mom were
once a part of the same crew under
Rock's leadership this group became the
most feared pirate crew in history and
went across the world doing whatever
they wanted with zero regards for the
repercussions or fear of being captured
and why would they fear there were no
Marines or Pirates strong enough to ever
stop them okay I know what you're
thinking how are these guys ever
defeated well you see rocks wasn't only
the world government's worst enemy he
was also the biggest rival of the pirate
king so the strongest Marine at that
time GARP and the strongest pirate
besides rocks Roger kingdomen finally
put an end to zedex tyranny the
interesting thing about this crew is
that after its disbandment every known
member became a famous pirate and formed
a crew of their own now in terms of
bounty this one is really hard to
estimate because we don't know a single
Bounty from the Rocks crew however based
on how much the world government wanted
him dead I'd say his Bounty was
definitely similar to Rogers if not iron
this would put his entire crew probably
at around 13 to 15 billion bellies click
on this video where we covered all
d-clan members in One Piece why are you
still here click it